what's going on here we need your help
welcome to your weekly ticket
amy adams next project has been
announced adams will play a woman who
thinks she's turning into a dog
in annapurna's night [ __ ] the project
is being adapted from rachel yoder's
upcoming debut novel by the same name
night [ __ ] is a dark comedy of a woman
and former artist
thrust into stay-at-home domesticity
after the birth of her son
who becomes increasingly worried and
convinced that she may be turning
into a dog the film marks the fifth
collaboration between annapurna and
adams
issa rae and jordan peele are teaming up
for a new genre film at universal
the film which is being adapted from a
short story by lena crowe follows a
young family that moves into its dream
home despite
a gaping sinkhole in the backyard the
mysterious sinkhole manages to fix
broken and destroyed things
but also explores the possibility of
that thing being
a person the announcement says the film
is a genre piece
that engages on the question of female
perfection and
identity the project is being developed
as a potential star vehicle for rey
and robert de niro anne hathaway and
oscar isaac are set to join cate
blanchett in
armageddon time the coming of age story
explores friendship
and loyalty against the backdrop of an
america poised to elect ronald reagan as
president the period drama will be
directed by james gray
and the story will draw from his own
childhood memories
the film will also star donald
sutherland who most recently
collaborated with gray on ad
astra well i threw on my
old team sports jersey because sports
are back
well they're kind of back but sports
movies are here
regardless of what happens with the
experiments with the big four leagues
which is why today i wanted to highlight
fandango now's list of 60
big league movies and today i have a
special guest for you
sports fan reporter for cnn frank
pallada frank what do you got for us
what are some
pics from this list that you recommend
so i have two picks the first pick is
going to be a baseball movie and it's
one of the best baseball movies of all
time it's a league of their own
and the reason that i picked the league
of their own is not just because of the
great performances by gina davis
and tom hanks who's actually playing
against type as one of the slobbiest
characters in movie history of jimmy
duggan
but also because it's a baseball movie
that takes place during a really
turbulent time world war
ii and that's what kind of led to the
all-girls league the the
sports leagues had to come together to
figure out how are we going to put on
baseball during a really traumatic time
during our nation's history which is
kind of like now so it's not only like a
really fun movie with some of the best
lines in sports movie history such as
you know there's no crying and baseball
but also it kind of speaks to our time
in a very comedic and fun way
absolutely yeah i've seen a lot of
people dress up as a league of their own
for halloween too that's how much of a
cult classic that is
yeah i just drink a bunch of beer and
then i'm dressed up as jimmy dugan
oh there you go uh the other one is
since baseball has been back but also we
have the nba coming back
i picked a seminal work of sports films
which is the classic known as space
chair so why did i pick yeah space jam
mwah so why did i pick space jam well
it's because we're kind of in like a
michael jordan renaissance right now if
you remember earlier in the pandemic
everyone was watching espn's docu series
the last dance which was about michael
jordan in the
1990s chicago bulls so this is kind of
like uh
epilogue to that you can watch michael
run around with bugs bunny and daffy
ducks shooting threes taking on aliens
which is probably the next thing that's
going to happen in 2020 because we've
had everything else
happen from murder hornets to you know
pandemic so
probably aliens are on their way but
it's also a really fun family film
everyone can really enjoy it it's a fun
little sports movie it's kind of weird
it has a little it has great cameos from
nba stars like charles barkley
and uh you know a great performance also
by bill murray
who you know is playing alongside uh
michael jordan but unfortunately never
got his chance to be a chicago bull
he did put up some big plays in the game
against the the monstars but
not nba quality yeah i think his his
years are over though i don't
do you think he could do it now i think
bill murray can do whatever
bill murray wants he has that power also
something to note is there is going to
be a sequel to space jam
coming out soon so this might be some
homework too
yeah it's uh we're supposed to get uh
space jam 2
next year with lebron james who many
would argue is a better player
than michael jordan that's a big
argument i don't know how i fall on that
but
you could argue it and i think it's a
good time for this to come back next
year because you know space jam is one
of those nostalgic
type of movies and the looney tunes
never really get old they've been around
since like
the 30s so this is going to be a fun
time so you can watch this movie prepare
for next year
and also use it to finish off all your
michael jordan love during the pandemic
now both of your movies somehow had
baseball in it but i
but i do want to know which sport
dominates
the film industry like is there one that
is more
inherently easy to adapt to film
yeah i think it's baseball i think
baseball is such a romantic
sport and cinema itself is romantic it
romanticizes reality
and when you think about all of the
moments that have really touched you in
sports movies
they have been things like you know the
the end of the natural where robert
redford hits that home run into the
lights and there's sparks and
all of that and of course spoiler alert
the end of field of dreams which i don't
want to give away but if you're not
crying at the end of field of dreams
go to a doctor right now because you
don't have a heart
it is just a beautiful movie and
baseball is kind of like life it's long
with these big
you know home run moments and movies
really are able to capture
the romance of baseball better than any
other sports in cinema
absolutely yeah i definitely cried at
that one
is there any particular film that you
think deserves a sequel
or reboot that kind of modernizes it or
like
makes a commentary on how that sport has
changed to date
so i think white man can't jump would be
in a great sequel
just because the nba has grown into such
a global league over these last couple
years and obviously that movie's not
about the nba it's more about basketball
but you can include so many great nba
cameos alongside woody harrelson and
wesley snipes two actors i really love
in that movie rosie perez too
and i just think it's a really fun kind
of way to kind of
update it maybe you can have uh woody
and wesley's characters play coaches
who have to kind of like go up against
each other once again
and i just think it's a good time for
that right now i could say you know
things like major league but they
actually made sequels that no one saw
so yeah i know there's a major league
too oh my god
but yeah white men can't jump they could
call it white man still can't jump
there you go he's doing all the work for
you all you're doing hollywood
money please all right well thank you so
much for
jumping on the show and and talking
sports with someone who's
only so so into the sports world i
appreciate it of course this was as they
would say
a slam dunk
[Music]
but if you're looking for some other
recommendations from our list of 60 big
league movies
here are a couple more that are based on
true stories that you can watch on
fandango now you smiling
why are you smiling football's fun you
think football is fun
yes no no remember the titans
is based on actual events that took
place in 1971 when a high school in
virginia is integrated with black
students from a nearby school
both schools are recognized for their
football program which are now unified
but when the black coach is chosen to be
the head coach of the newly integrated
team
the previous head coach is left with
feelings of animosity
the film stars denzel washington will
patton wood harris
and ryan gosling also available to watch
at home
miracle back in 1960 coach brooks was on
the olympic hockey team
but a week before the games his coach
cuts him and sends him home
and that team went on to win the gold
medal without him
miracle tells the story of a team that
transcended its sport and united a
nation with a new feeling of hope
based on the true story of one of the
greatest moments in sports history
the tale captures a time and place where
differences could be settled by games
and
a cold war could be put on ice in 1980
the united states ice hockey team coach
er brooks
took a team of college kids up against
the legendary juggernaut from the soviet
union
at the olympic games despite the long
odds team usa carried the pride of a
nation
yearning for a distraction from the
world events
alright well that's it for today make
sure to check out that full list of 60
big league movies we'll leave a link
below and leave us a comment and let us
know which one is your favorite
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
you